three degrees
it can be the difference between snow
and sleet
wearing a jacket or not
in your day-to-day life it may not seem
significant
but three degrees of global warming
would be catastrophic
[Music]
heatwaves
droughts extreme precipitation even fire
three degrees of warming is really
disastrous
the scary thing is the world is well on
its way there
since the industrial revolution the
earth has warmed between 1.1 and 1.3
degrees celsius
this is a problem that
babies you pass in the street will have
to live with
children born today are up to seven
times more likely to face extreme
weather than their grandparents
if global temperatures do rise by three
degrees what would their world look like
rising sea levels
desertification
hollywood has always enjoyed imagining
the end of the world
while blockbusters like this are clearly
fiction this film will show the scenario
we all face
unless more drastic measures are taken
to stop burning fossil fuels
[Music]
in some parts of the world the effects
of inaction are already clear
the slums of bangladesh's capital are
filling up with climate migrants
minara comes from bola district an area
in southern bangladesh
there like many other parts of the
country
rivers swollen by heavier rain and
melting himalayan glaciers are washing
away people's homes
many like her have lost everything
1.1 to 1.3 degrees of global warming has
already transformed minara's life
it's one of the reasons why so many
migrants like her are moving to the city
each year nearly four hundred thousand
according to the last estimate
and climate models show there could be
much worse to come
climate scientist yuri rogel has spent
the last 10 years modeling future
climate scenarios for the united nations
the models we use to carry out this
exercise really represent the state of
the art of our current knowledge of
climate change and where we are heading
yuri's projections use data collected by
hundreds of scientists around the world
here this is the three degree level and
so there is
at least a one in four chance that under
current policies we would hit three
degrees by the end of the century
this is just one of the scenarios yuri
looks at
another one imagined that all policy
promises are kept
the most optimistic assumes that all
promises have been kept and net zero
targets are met
where our best estimate ends up around 2
degrees at the end of the century there
is still a 1 in 20 chance that we end up
with 3 degrees instead one wouldn't be
entering a plane if there is a 1 in 20
chance that the plane will crash
a rise of 3 degrees would affect
everyone even wealthy cities and rich
countries wouldn't be immune to the
consequences
european capitals like paris and berlin
would bake under more extreme heat waves
frequent storm surges in new york could
turn parts of the city desolate
in many ways cities um magnify intensify
climate events cities are hotter than
the places around them they tend to be
more
vulnerable to flooding and you can get a
really bad event in the city in a way
that you can't in the countryside
and because of their denser populations
disasters in a city affect far more
people
some cities might be badly prepared for
the changes coming but they have the
means to adapt
cities tend to be wealthier um than
surrounding places they have a lot of
amenities a city that has taken
seriously the risks of a three-degree
world wouldn't necessarily be a worse
place to be in a three-degree world but
a city that hasn't prepared for these
sort of eventualities that might be a
really nasty place
[Music]
so far many developed cities have gotten
off lightly
but some rural parts of the world are
suffering disproportionately
smallholders small-scale farmers
are particularly vulnerable to climate
change
and there are over 600 million around
the world small holders with farms under
two hectares produce around a third of
the global food supply
central america's dry corridor supports
a mix of small holdings and medium-sized
farms
sandwiched between the pacific ocean and
the caribbean sea
the area is prone to droughts
[Music]
israel ramirez rivera is a small holder
in guatemala
here climate change is making the dry
seasons longer
and more severe
he depends on his crops of corn and
beans but they're getting harder to grow
last month
[Music]
nearly two-thirds of the small holders
in the dry corridor now live in poverty
nutrition
foreign
severe droughts in central america are
now four times more likely than they
were last century
migration from guatemala to the united
states has quadrupled since 1990.
[Music]
not all of this has been due to climate
change
but longer droughts would force even
more to move
in a three degree world annual rainfall
in this region could drop by up to 14
percent
at three degrees over a quarter of the
world's population could endure extreme
droughts for at least a month of the
year
northern africa could see droughts that
last for years at a time
but for some too much water will be the
problem
10 of the world's population lives on a
coastline that's less than 10 meters
above sea level
for these coastal inhabitants a
three-degree world would spell disaster
by 2100
global sea levels could have climbed by
half a meter from 2005 levels low-lying
cities like lagos would be especially
vulnerable with up to a third of the
population displaced
and in fiji rising waters are already
upending lives
you can see the graveyard
in solano water now due to this rising
sea level and climate change
[Music]
the village of toguru in fiji is being
swallowed by the sea
barney dunn the village hedman has seen
over half the village disappear
relatives houses have been abandoned and
family graves are now under water
we've been asked by the government to
relocate
but no one wants to relocate because we
have our great great grandparents down
here in the sea
this is the place we've been brought up
in it's not easy to live
[Music]
past attempts to build a sea wall
haven't worked
but barney sees building a new one as
the village's only hope
if they do that maybe we can save
whatever is left but if
we don't have the sea wall then it will
keep eroding and
time will come maybe in 10
the world will be only road
rising seas also mean storms cause more
floods
and many more countries could suffer
the philippines and myanmar are just two
countries that will also see an increase
in storm surges in a three-degree world
to escape
many will move
often to urban areas
half the world's population already
lives in cities
almost a third in slums
for them a three degree world could be
deadly
minara has moved to dhaka to escape the
impact of climate change
but life
in the last 20 years the average daytime
temperature has crept up by nearly half
a degree
days that approach 40 are now being
reported
and high so-called wet bulb temperatures
are on the rise
a wet bulb temperature is a measure of
heat and humidity
humans cool themselves by sweating but
in these conditions when relative
humidity is near 100 percent
sweat doesn't evaporate well so people
can't cool down
even if given unlimited shade and water
at a high wet bulb temperature the body
can't lose heat and so it gets hotter
and hotter and the body is designed to
work at a given temperature and if it
gets too hot inside you will die
the human limit for wet bulb
temperatures is 35 degrees celsius
around skin temperature
daca will have a much higher chance of
reaching dangerous wet bulb temperatures
if global warming reaches 3 degrees
you can't really adapt to that you have
to get out
if the temperature is so high that you
can't work
you can't do hard manual labor outside
for significant parts of the year then
many places will become
functionally no longer part of the
economy
jacobabad in pakistan and ross al qaima
in the united arab emirates have already
recorded deadly wet bulb temperatures
more of the tropics and the persian gulf
as well as parts of mexico and the
southeastern united states could all get
to this threshold by the end of the
century
climate modeling might show us the
weather but it doesn't show us its other
effects on society
established migration patterns could
change
climate disasters may exacerbate reasons
people cross borders
within countries more people will move
to cities
in a three-degree world tens of millions
of people a year could be displaced by
disasters made worse by climate change
when people are displaced by climate
they may well go to cities because
cities are the places that attract
people from the countryside
already
a lot of people who can get to the
developed world not only because the
developed world tends to be less hot
will give that a go
[Music]
as migration around the world increases
there could be more competition for
fewer resources
water
already a highly contested resource will
be a focal
point turkey's new illuso dam has
reduced the flow of water into iraq
china lays claim to rivers vital to
india and pakistan
the prospect of a water conflict makes
people very uneasy
how national tensions would exacerbate
those sorts of reactions in a
three-degree world is the sort of thing
that no one should really want to find
out
i think you'd have to be incredibly
sanguine not to think that the sort of
climate extremes that we talk about in a
three-degree world wouldn't lead some
places to the brink of societal collapse
those lucky enough to escape unrest
would still have to adapt to a radically
different world
people can adapt to climate change in
all sorts of ways one of the most
obvious ones is
air conditioning but other ways to adapt
at a local or regional level i mean one
of the most obvious
is diversifying agriculture
there are physical things you can do
like sea walls
the fact that people can adapt and that
adaptation will reduce suffering
doesn't mean that it will eliminate
suffering
suffering is built into this whole
process of heating up the planet
adaptation will only get the world so
far
the best way to deal with a three degree
world is not to go to a three degree
world that's why increasing efforts on
mitigation are important it's why
working towards negative emissions that
could bring down the temperature after
it peaks are important
once you get to a three degree world you
are in real
bad
global trouble
the scale of change needed and the slow
progress of government so far
means three degrees of warming is
uncomfortably likely unless more is done
[Music]
despite existing pledges
greenhouse gas emissions are still set
to rise by 16 from 2010 levels by 2030.
the need to act has never been clearer
there's still time to reduce emissions
so that a three-degree world remains
fiction
rather than becoming fact
[Music]
thanks for watching
to read the economist's cover package on
what a three degree world might look
like click on the link
and don't forget to subscribe
[Music]
you